uh during the first day of judge katanji
brown jackson's confirmation hearings
and by the first day i mean monday
um the former president donald trump
attempted to do some counter-programming
uh wherein he gave an interview to fox
business host
stuart varney and this was a very
dangerous and corrosive interview and
we're going to look at a couple of clips
of it and there is one segment here
where donald trump provocatively wants
to talk about the n-word but it's not
the n-word you think of he's talking
about nuclear or nuclear depending on
your preferred pronunciation here is
donald trump talking about putin
and
nuclear well in hope to god you never
have to use it because it would be that
would be the tragedy of all tragedies
but if we didn't have it we couldn't
talk but i listened to him constantly
using the n-word that's the n-word
and he's constantly using it the nuclear
word right and we never
talk if we say oh he's a nuclear power
so trump there i i don't know if he
thinks it's clever or what to refer to
nuclear as the n-word but stuart varney
is
visibly perplexed by it then stuart
varney made a big mistake
stuart varney tried asking donald trump
about policy and as you know and as i
know and as many of our viewers know
when you ask trump about policy you do
not get an answer it's almost satirical
at this point
there's this discussion about whether we
should send jets mig jets to help the
ukraine air force would you send in that
kind of help
well maybe even more to be honest with
you and i'm the only one
stayed out i'm the one that would have
stayed out let me just explain that
putin is saying things like
don't you dare send anything in in the
meantime he's killing thousands of
thousands of people so he's acting like
we're an aggressor if we send in some
old 44 year old flame
that probably gets shot out of the sky
pretty quickly
and he's acting like we're terrible
people if we do that
but he's killing tens of thousands of
people far more than they're reporting
you don't knock down those buildings and
blow up those buildings and they say two
people were injured slightly yeah so the
question was would you send in the jets
and trump says i might even send more
and then the question is well what
exactly would you send and trump's off
on a tangent he later is able varney is
able to get trump back on track
and then there's the question of well
okay what exactly would you do and trump
says well i might send nuclear subs to
intimidate nobody knows where they are
and you should say look you if you
mention that word one more time
we're going to send them over and we'll
be coasting back and forth up and down
your coast you can't let this tragedy
continue you can't let these these
thousands of people die it's gonna be
hundreds of thousands and maybe millions
of people by the time it ends right so i
guess trump is at the same time that he
has been very hesitant to criticize
vladimir putin and at the same time that
he delayed sending military aid to
ukraine because he wanted dirt on biden
he's also saying he would be more
aggressive than joe biden but at the
same time saying he would have kept us
out of war so as you can tell this is
what we might call in the academic world
a very complicated text uh if you would
keep us out of wars why would you be be
doing more aggression than joe biden
it's all sort of confusing
later the topic goes and this is a very
dangerous topic for the former president
climate change and varney asks a a very
specific question and trump gives a very
bizarre answer
somebody said i don't even think ever
took a course in the environment is the
climate
change is the climate changing because
of human activity
in my opinion uh you have a thing called
weather and you go up and you go down if
you look into the 1920s they were
talking about global freezing okay in
other words the globe was going to
freeze and then they go global warming
then they couldn't use that because the
temperatures were actually quite cool
and many different things so now they
just talk about climate change the
climate's always been changing okay so
and as we know donald trump is one of
the foremost uh authorities on climate
and as as well as on renewable energy
right i mean you guys remember his
expertise there the noise causes cancer
yeah uh so um lastly in this just a very
it was a sort of a like a subdued
low-energy trump he almost sounded
slightly ill maybe he had just woken up
uh
varney asks trump
what should be the
uh
uh let me see how i can even trump says
the focus for republicans in 2022 and
2024 should be how joe biden stole stole
the election from him in 2020. if we go
into 2022 the elections we by the way
2024
and you're still looking back to the
election of 2020 and saying that you
really won
i don't know that's very good for you or
the republican party it's not a comment
on that
well i yeah i actually think it is good
for me and i think if we don't
uh
put out all of the crooked things that
we know what they are
that you won't win in 22 and you won't
win in 24. i think what trump means is
if if we don't keep talking about that
people will forget about me we don't get
to it so i think it's the opposite
actually and i talked nothing about
nobody talks more about the future you
think that 2022.
you think that 2022 and 2024 are all
about the 2020 election right right no
no no i think for us to win the election
we have to know how they cheated because
otherwise they'll cheat again and we do
know how they cheated okay and
republican but so then why do you need
to talk about it right i mean it doesn't
make any sense what this is this is
really just
it needs to be about me for the next
three years and democrats should but
they won't republicans have to do
something about it or they're going to
be very disappointed and nobody talks
more about the future than i do but you
have to learn from history also and you
can't let it happen again soon right
right that would be a real shame as
donald trump likes to say so a very
strange interview and sort of an attempt
at counter programming
the confirmation hearings of judge
katanji brown jackson there it is we'll
have the clips on our instagram which
you can find at david pakman show and
i'll have more information for you about
uh upcoming events that we'll be
covering very soon
one of our sponsors today is emmy the
world's first low carb high protein 100
plant-based instant ramen emmy has only
six net carbs perfect if you're doing
keto or low carb unlike regular ramen it
has 21 grams of protein helping you feel
fuller longer
18 grams of fiber that's four times more
than most other ramen brands and emmy
also has 35 percent less sodium than
competitors so you don't get that bloat
and thirst imi uses only high quality
ingredients they don't use a lot of
preservatives that many other ramen
brands use i love making emmy ramen as a
snack just like any other instant ramen
you put it in the microwave ready in a
few minutes i love adding green onion
and mushrooms to it yummy comes in spicy
beef tom yum shrimp black garlic chicken
i've tried all three they're all
delicious and they're plant-based right
now emmy is giving my audience five
dollars off when you go to
emmyeats.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below